ein urteil mit enormen folgen das
klimaschutzgesetz geht nicht weit genug
und ist teilweise verfassungswidrig
sagen die höchsten deutschen richter
[Musik]
amerika ist wieder in bewegung erklärt
der präsident vor dem us kongress nach
100 tagen im amt und der tiefe fall von
christoph metzelder
weil er kinderpornografische dateien
verschickt hat wird der ex
nationalspieler zu einer
bewährungsstrafe verurteilt
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
heute um 7 zusammen mit dem sport den
arbeitnehmern präsentiert einen schönen
guten antwort von mir und wir beginnen
mit einem urteil des
bundesverfassungsgerichts das schon
jetzt bahnbrechend und historisch
genannt wird das klimaschutzgesetz aus
dem jahr 2009 10 ist zum teil
verfassungswidrig weil es die
natürlichen lebensgrundlagen künftiger
generationen nicht gut genug geschützt
das klimaschutzgesetz regelt ja wie viel
treibhausgase ausgestoßen werden dürfen
ganz konkret beispielsweise in den
bereichen verkehr oder landwirtschaft
aber nur für die nächsten jahre
die richter und richterinnen sagen damit
würden zu große lasten auf die zeit nach
2030 verschoben und die jungen
generation in ihrer freiheit
eingeschränkt günther neufeld berichtet
sie hatten 2020 verfassungsbeschwerde
eingelegt junge leute aus der freude is
for future bewegung unterstützt von der
deutschen umwelthilfe und anderen
verbänden jetzt ist die freude groß dass
gibt auch uns als klimabewegung einer
totalen vorschub und wir werden es
energie jetzt mitnehmen in den sommer
und auch in die bundestagswahl 2021 die
kritik der richterinnen und richter nur
bis 2030 mache das gesetz präzise
vorgaben zum klimaschutz was danach
passieren soll dürfe man aber nicht
einfach offen lassen
deutschland hat sich verpflichtet dazu
beizutragen die klimaerwärmung auf einen
wert von deutlich unter zwei grad zu
begrenzen
die gesetzlichen maßnahmen die bis 2030
vorgesehen sind reichen dafür aber nicht
aus sagt das gericht und die lasten die
der klimaschutz für die bürger mit sich
bringt dürfen auch nicht einfach in die
zukunft verschoben werden die auflage
des gerichts im interesse der jungen
generation muss die politik bis ende
nächsten jahres per gesetz festlegen wie
es nach 2030 weiter gehen soll
die spd habe sich dafür schon früher
eingesetzt meint der vizekanzler
das ist am widerstand auch aus dem
wirtschaftsministerium gescheitert
deshalb müssen wir das jetzt ändern
es ist ganz klar das
wirtschaftsministerium ist
an vielen stellen auf der bremse was der
wirtschaftsminister zurückweist auch er
habe schon weitergehende vorschläge
gemacht es hilft nicht der blick zurück
sondern es hilft der blick nach vorn
wir müssen das urteil des
bundesverfassungsgerichtes akzeptieren
in all seinen aspekten wir müssen es
umsetzen und zwar möglichst schnell wie
man klimaschädliche abgase auch nach
2030 weiter reduziert die gespräche dazu
in der regierungskoalition sollen
nächste woche beginnen
theo koll in berlin das urteil bestätigt
was klimaschützer innen schon immer
sagen wir leben auf kosten künftiger
generationen was heißt das jetzt für die
bundesregierung
außer einer erneuten heftigen ohrfeige
vom höchsten deutschen gericht bedeutet
es unmittelbar eher wenig die
umweltministerin hat zwar sofort
angekündigt im sommer eckpunkte führen
weiter entwickelt das klimaschutzgesetz
vorzulegen aber die umsetzung glaube ich
dürfte er auf dem arbeitszettel der
nächsten regierung landen aber es wird
sehr viel für uns alle bedeuten denn
aktuell und absehbar verbrauchen wir
noch viel zu viel co2 und wir
verschieben damit massive lasten auf die
künftige generation das heißt wir alle
werden uns viel radikaler umstellen
müssen im verkehr in der landwirtschaft
gebäudeisolierung usw
das spektakuläre an diesem urteil ist
dass der gesetzgeber gezwungen wird
rechtzeitig für die nächste generation
vorzusorgen für klimapolitik sind die
wahlperioden ja bisher immer zu kurz
gewesen
man stelle sich das mal auf andere
bereiche übertragen vor rente
gesundheits und pflegekosten also wenn
die zukunft über die gegenwart mit
entscheiden darf das ist etwas wirklich
besonderes ein ernster ausblick von theo
vielen dank dafür aus nach berlin
mehr gegen den klimawandel tun das will
auch us-präsident beiden nur eins der
themen die er in den ersten 100 tagen
seiner amtszeit angegangen ist
im kampf gegen korona kann beiden darauf
verweisen dass bereits mehr als die
hälfte aller amerikaner mindestens
einmal geimpft ist und mit einem 2
billionen dollar infrastrukturpaket will
er jede menge jobs schaffen
von dem vor dem kongress verbreitete
beiden deshalb aufbruchstimmung elmar
theveßen
wenn ihnen liz cheney führende
republikanerin die begrüßungs faust
gewährt der wichtigste linke seiner
partei bernie sanders ihn beinahe umarmt
und erstmals in der geschichte zwei
frauen den vorsitz führen ist das kein
schlechter start für diesen präsident
amerika ist wieder in bewegung
impfkampagne das corona hilfspaket die
wirtschaft zieht an und beiden drückt
aufs tempo warum soll windturbinen nicht
den pittsburgh statt in peking gebaut
werden können
mein plan ist eine arbeiter orientierte
blaupause für den wiederaufbau amerika
beiden verspricht den staat als kümmerer
auch kostenlose kinderbetreuung und
fachhochschul- bildung gesamtpreis
schild über 6 billionen dollar
finanziert durch steuererhöhungen für
die reicheren es ist zeit dass die
konzerne und das reichste 1 prozent der
amerikaner ihren gerechten anteil
leisten umverteilung das gefällt den
republikanern gar nicht sie werfen
beiden auch untätigkeit bei der
illegalen einwanderung vor nur seine
ansage an china gefällt ihnen eine
starke militärpräsenz im indopazifik
sowie mit der nato in europa nicht um
einen konflikt zu starten sondern zu
verhindern
bei der innenpolitischen agenda von joe
biden und camilla harris ist konflikt
wohl unvermeidlich doch mit ihren ersten
100 tagen ist die mehrheit der
amerikaner recht zufrieden
es ist gelungen die dritte corona welle
abzubremsen sagt der chef des robert
koch-instituts wiler das zeigen auch die
aktuellen zahlen innerhalb von 24
stunden registrierte das lka gut 24.700
neuinfektionen 4782 weniger als
vergangenen donnerstag 264 neue
todesfälle kamen dazu die bundesweite
incidents ist erneut gesunken auf 154,9
einen neuen rekord
gibt es bei den impfzahlen wurden bisher
maximal knapp 800.000 dosen verabreicht
so waren es gestern mehr als eine
million
und auch beim thema impfschutz für
kinder und jugendliche gibt es eine
positive entwicklung der hersteller bei
montech weise hofft dass sein impfstoff
für die altersgruppe der zwölf- bis
15-jährigen schon in den nächsten wochen
zugelassen wird spätestens in den
sommerferien könnten dann auch mädchen
und jungen ab zwölf jahren geimpft
werden so gesundheitsminister sparen
impfen von kindern und warum eltern
nicht früher dran sind bei diesen themen
können sie mitdiskutieren in zdf heute
live unter anderem mit dem vorsitzenden
der ständigen impfkommission thomas
mertens um halb acht in der zdf- heute-
app und auf unseren social social media
kanälen angespannt bleibt die lage auf
deutschlands intensivstation
von den gut 5000 schwer kranken corona
patienten bundesweit muss mehr als die
hälfte beatmet werden
in nordrhein westfalen sind es so viele
wie noch nie
aus bochum ein bericht von torge bode
die intensivstation des st josefs
hospitals in bochum alle 18 betten sind
hier belegt die hälfte davon mit cupid
19 patientinnen von einer entspannung
der situation kann hier keine rede sein
im gegenteil in der lage alle patienten
behandeln zu können aber auch wir merken
mittlerweile das wohl personell als auch
betten technischen kapazitäten durchaus
klar waren
anderswo sind die kapazitäten zeitweise
erschöpft dieser kurve patient wurde aus
der uniklinik köln nach bochum verlegt
um die versorgung von akuten notfällen
in köln zu gewährleisten mussten gleich
mehrere patientinnen auf andere kliniken
aufwendig umverteilt werden
das ist für deutschland schon eine
besonderheit köln ist ja nun mal auch
eine bedeutende millionenstadt und wenn
dort schon die kapazität nicht mehr
ausreichen dann wird einem klar wie
ernst es dort ist
in belgien ist die lage noch ernster es
gibt fast keine freien intensivbetten
mehr
deutschland soll jetzt corona patienten
aufnehmen und kann das auch denn die
versorgungslage ist regional
unterschiedlich hellere flecken auf der
karte zeigen wo noch ausreichend
intensivbetten zur verfügung stehen dass
es noch kapazitäten gibt schreiben
intensivmediziner den corona maßnahmen
und den steigenden impfzahlen zu
das ende der dritten welle will man aber
noch nicht ausrufen
auf keinen fall ein grund zur entwarnung
es ist die hoffnung dass die maßnahmen
der notbremse so langsam ihre wirkung
auch auf unseren stationen verhalten
aber immer noch weit über 5.000
patienten kein grund zur entwarnung aber
die intensivmedizinische versorgung ist
hierzulande derzeit nicht gefährdet
die bundesregierung plant offenbar für
vollständig geimpfte und genesene
deutlich größere befreiungen als bisher
bekannt ein entwurf von justizminister
lambrecht sieht vor dass sie von
kontakt- und ausgangs beschränkungen
ausgenommen werden das kabinett soll
kommende woche über den vorschlag
beraten zum arbeitsmarkt in deutschland
trotzt pandemie bleibt eher stabil weil
über drei millionen menschen durch
kurzarbeit in ihren jobs gehalten werden
und weil im frühjahr die wirtschaft
saison bedingt zulegt so sind im
laufenden monat zwei millionen 771 1000
arbeitslose registriert 56.000 weniger
als im märz
die quote sinkt leicht auf 6,0 prozent
im vergleich zum april 2020 sind 127
1000 menschen mehr ohne job
beleidigungen drohungen tätliche
angriffe erfahrungen die mehr als die
hälfte aller kommunalpolitiker innen
schon gemacht haben tendenz stark
zunehmend von einer bedrohung der
demokratie spricht heute bundespräsident
steinmeier zum start eines
internetportals mit wichtigen
hilfestellungen für betroffene orte
färbe
lüdenscheid am rande des sauerlands hat
seit 24 jahren seinen stadtkämmerer
doch nun will karl heinz blasweiler
aufgeben mit 58 jahren auch mein hass
und hetze in seinem berufsalltag zu viel
geworden sind am schlimmsten angefangen
dass man morddrohungen über anonyme
anzeigen bis hin zu beschimpfungen und
beleidigungen belästigungen das ist wo
der ganze katalog der sich über die
jahre hinweg gezeigt hat hass und gewalt
gegen kommunalpolitiker innen nehmen zu
nach einer aktuellen umfrage sind 57
prozent im bürgermeisteramt beleidigt
bedroht oder tätlich angegriffen worden
mehr als ein drittel der betroffenen
verzichtet inzwischen auf die nutzung
sozialer medien fast jeder fünfte denkt
über rückzug aus der politik nach stark
im amt will der bundespräsident nun
kommunalpolitikerinnen machen heute
schaltet er ein internetportal dazu frei
hier können betroffene hilfe finden und
auch tipps zur vorbeugung
das gefährdet die grundfesten unserer
demokratie wenn sich bürgermeister oder
gemeinderatsmitglieder vor bestimmten
themen fürchten müssen
dann geraten debatten und
entscheidungsprozesse in eine schieflage
unsere gesellschaft insgesamt muss auf
warum reagieren lüdenscheid
stadtkämmerer aber hat seinen entschluss
gefasst ende juni scheidet er aus dem
amt aus aussenminister mars ist nach
afghanistan gereist in ein land das
besorgt in die zukunft blickt denn die
nato hat nach fast 20 jahren ihren
rückzug beschlossen der hat heute
begonnen und soll bis zum herbst
abgeschlossen sein
1100 bundeswehrsoldaten sind aktuell
noch dort wo sie abziehen droht neue
gewalt andreas cüppers berichtet
die taliban sind wieder da sie schlagen
sie schüchtern ein sie töten die bilder
von den zerstörten geschäften und den
männern die stolz auf diese zerstörungen
sind stammen aus der provinz balkh die
20 jahre unter dem schutz der bundeswehr
stand camp marmal in masar i scharif ist
ihr größtes lager im ausland bis august
soll es geräumt sein
der deutsche außenminister reist
unangekündigt und martialisch bewacht in
einer hauptstadt voller sorgen die
friedensgespräche mit den taliban sind
festgefahren ausländer reisen ab
einheimische fliegen gegenüber präsident
gar nie sagt maaß die fortsetzung der
zivilen unterstützung zu 430 millionen
euro pro jahr
deutschland geht aber nicht so ganz mit
blick auf die zukunft setzen wir darauf
dass die taliban verstanden haben dass
die konflikte in afghanistan politisch
gelöst werden müssen und ist nie eine
militärische lösung geben wird
in diesen tagen beginnen die usa zu
packen zu verschrotten obwohl sie wissen
dass es der afghanischen armee nicht an
ausrüstung aber an moral fehlt so
unpopulär der afghanistan einsatz in
deutschland ist für die regierung hier
für die wirtschaft aber vor allem für
die bevölkerung ist der truppenabzug die
katastrophe die vielen kleinen
fortschritte sind in gefahr weil es den
einen großen fortschritt
nie gab in masar i scharif gedenken an
die 59 bundeswehr soldaten die in
afghanistan ums leben kamen die frage
war es das wert wird die bundespolitik
noch lange quälen zu einem ganz anderen
thema bis zum september 2009 10 stand
der name christoph metzelder für eine
erfolgreiche fußball-karriere auch die
zukunft als tv-kommentator schienen
gesichert
dann der bruch auf seinem handy werden
kinder und jugendpornografische dateien
sichergestellt
heute wurde er verurteilt das gefängnis
aber bleibt ihm erspart dominik müller
russ l
das medieninteresse heute am amtsgericht
düsseldorf riesig der angeklagte um
sachlichkeit bemüht doch als er gesteht
18 kinder und jugendpornografische
bilder und videos verschickt zu haben
kämpft christoph metzelder mit den
tränen am nachmittag bereits das urteil
zehn monate haft auf bewährung
bei der strafzumessung hat das gericht
berücksichtigt dass der angeklagte sich
hier geständig eingelassen hat er
bislang nicht vorbestraft ist und auch
echte reue gezeigt hat warum verschickt
ein ehemaliger fußball-nationalspieler
der sich besonders für kinderrechte
stark gemacht hat kinderpornografische
bilder die faszination habe für ihn in
der grenzüberschreitung gelegen so
christoph metzelder heute nicht in die
darstellungen schwersten sexuellen
missbrauchs selbst glaube ich heute auch
sehr eindrucksvoll getan
zehn monate auf bewährung das urteil
erklären prozessbeobachter auch damit
dass das gericht die umfangreiche
mediale berichterstattung über christoph
metzelder und kinderpornografische
bilder mit berücksichtigt habe auf der
anderen seite aber auch die
gesellschaftliche ächtung die damit
einhergeht
er wird auf absehbare zeit nicht mehr am
gesellschaftlichen leben teilnehmen
können so das gericht
am ende bietet christoph metzelder heute
die anwesenden um entschuldigung
stellvertretend für alle opfer sexueller
gewalt
trauer und fassungslosigkeit in potsdam
dort sind in einem diakonischen wohnheim
für behinderte vier bewohner getötet
worden
so viel man bislang weiß sollen sie
durch schwere äußere gewaltanwendung
gestorben sein
eine weitere person wurde schwer
verletzt aufgefunden
als dringend tatverdächtig gilt eine 51
jährige mitarbeiterin das zuständige
amtsgericht hat sie in eine psychiatrie
eingewiesen
zum möglichen motiv gibt es noch keine
informationen
berlin feiert heute die rückkehr eine
berühmtheit eine ikone der kunstwelt
international gefeiert es geht um die
neue nationalgalerie
das museum ist jetzt sozusagen noch neue
weil komplett saniert architektur aus
granit stahl und glas 1968 entstand der
bau viele bedeutsame ausstellungen und
auch konzerte später musste renoviert
werden und nun strahlt berlins sachlich
schlichte schönheit wieder stephan
merseburger ein museum dass selbst ein
kunstwerk ist die neue nationalgalerie
in berlin
die architektur ein großer wurf nach
sechs jahren sanierung heute morgen die
schlüsselübergabe
der festakt pandemie bedingt im kleinen
kreis die eröffnung 1968 dagegen war
eine echte party da werden sehnsüchte
wachen mies van der rohe der brillante
deutsche architekt der die nazis ins
amerikanische exil vertrieben hatten
bekam den auftrag
es gab gefeierte ausstellungen
besucherscharen zog die kollektion des
new yorker moma 2004 an
auch die schau von deutschlands kunst ag
hat richter 2012 war ein publikumsmagnet
nach 50 jahren betrieb war das haus
heruntergewirtschaftet die heikle
aufgabe der sanierung übernahm der
britische stararchitekt david
chipperfield die nationalgalerie wurde
in 35.000 teile zerlegt originale
erhalten so viel mies wie möglich lautet
dabei die devise
wir wussten dass unsere anwesenheit nur
durch unsere fehler sichtbar werden
würde
neu sind die fenster die alten waren
nicht zu retten
es sind spezialanfertigungen aus china
wärmedämmung fußbodenheizung
led-beleuchtung das haus ist jetzt
technisch auf dem stand der dinge
und doch sieht es aus wie früher berlins
tempel der moderne ist zurück zum sport
und dann geht es auch heute gilt er als
erstes und die fußball-champions-league
norbert denn da gab es ja gestern abend
das zweite halbfinal hinspiel zwischen
paris st germain und manchester city
pep guardiolas team gewann mit 2 2 1 und
hat mit diesem auswärtssieg die tür zum
champions league finale weit aufgerissen
so dicht dran am finale war pep
guardiola noch nie seit seinem wechsel
von bayern zu manchester city
jetzt ist es zum greifen nahe die
vorjahresfinalisten aus paris machten
den gästen das leben einer halbe
halbzeit lang schwer
martin joos führungstreffer schon nach
15 minuten mitte der zweiten hälfte bei
den pariser gegenwehr gänzlich dahin
gebräuntes ausgleich zum 1 1
hochverdient für den tabellenführer der
englischen premier league
die entscheidung fiel durch ein loch in
der mauer war es hat entdeckt 2 1
gewinnt city im prinzenpark aus
deutscher sicht nicht unwichtig
nationalspieler gündogan hat dieses volk
von ge unbeschadet überstanden anders
als der senegalese der dafür rot sah für
manchester city wäre ist übrigens das
erste champions league finale führt
julia endspiel nummer drei die deutsche
handball nationalmannschaft hat auch ihr
fünftes gruppenspiel in der em
qualifikation gewonnen
das dhb team siegte gegen bosnien
herzegowina mit 26 zu 24 mitte der
ersten hälfte deutet einiges auf einen
ungefährdeten sieg hin vieles geht
leicht von der hand wie der kunst wurf
von marcel schiller mit zehn toren der
treffsicherste spieler doch die bosnier
kämpften sich zurück und erzielte zwei
sekunden vor der halbzeitsirene den
ausgleich 15 zu 15
nach dem wechsel bleibt es ein hartes
ringen um jeden ball
deutschland verteidigt eine knappe
führung timo casting zum endstand von 26
zu 24 deutschland bereits qualifiziert
behält seine weiße weste und bayern
münchen hat im viertelfinale der
basketball euroleague die chance auf ein
weiterkommen gewahrt
nach zwei niederlagen gewinnt das team
im dritten spiel der best of five serie
gegen armani mailand mit 85 79
herausragend der münchner wladimir lutz
mit 27 punkten
es ist der erste sieg einer deutschen
mannschaft bei den playoffs überhaupt
und das was im sport da genau dies war
der kälteste april seit 40 jahren meldet
der deutsche wetterdienst ob es am
ersten maiwochenende wärmer wird das
verrät uns gleich katja horneffer das
war es von uns danke für ihr interesse
christian sievers erwartet sie um
viertel vor zehn zum heute journal
und wir sind morgen um 7 wieder da
entspannten abend wünschen wäre es
[Musik]
meine damen und herren der april 2021
war zu trocken im vergleich zum
vieljährigen klimatologischen mittel der
jahre 1991 bis 2020 kam nur etwa 75
prozent dessen runter anregen was wir
sonst erwarten könnten natürlich gab es
regionale unterschiede
im schnitt waren das in deutschland so
35 liter pro quadratmeter
und das bedeutet es gibt einige regionen
in denen in den nächsten tagen bis
sonntag deutlich mehr regen fällt als im
ganzen monat april am alpenrand erwarten
wir bis zu 60 liter in norddeutschland
bis zu 20 in der mitte um die fünf liter
dahinter stecken einige tiefs heute ist
ja schon 1 heran gezogen sein zentrum
liegt jetzt über norddeutschland ist
brachte schon regen mit einige schauer
und auch kurze gewitter und mit schauern
haben wir es jetzt auch noch in der
nacht zu tun
besonders im norden aber auch im
südosten dazwischen aber ist es klar und
dann sinken die temperaturen in den
mittelgebirgen auf plus 1 bis minus ein
grad
es droht also bodenfrost die
höchsttemperaturen morgen liegen meist
bei 10 bis 14 grad etwas wärmer wird es
an der donau mit 80 grad sonst gibt es
wieder viele wolken und auch einige
regenschauer vor allen dingen im
nordwesten und im südwesten und eher
wechselhaft geht es dann auch über den
maifeiertag bis zum montag weiter
dennoch